what is a woman
you are not you're not a woman you don't
look like a woman you don't act like a
woman at the same time my god if you're
three years old and you're saying you're
feeling a certain way you're you're you
think you're a boy or girl whatever the
case may be here and that's what's being
promoted to our children as young as age
three he's like wow i don't think kids
should be trans i mean they're little
babies and they're like what
are you serious
yes i lived eight years as laura jensen
until i woke up brothers and sisters
we're halfway there this is your brother
eddie from the dean show and
alhamdulillah we are purchasing a 35 000
square foot property to build the dean
center a dawah center a masjid the first
of its kind in america and we are
halfway there to closing on the property
we have 700 000 left that must be
collected this month in order to close
on the property get the tremendous
rewards by helping to build the dean's
center with us by donating right now may
god almighty allah reward all of you
assalamu alaikum greetings and peace
welcome to the dean show i'm eddie your
host and my next guest
brenda lipsack
runs brenda for kids
the purpose of brenda for kids is to
pull back the curtain on what's really
going on in public education
parents have been left in the dark about
many changes concerning educational
content laws policies and the fast
erosion of parental rights
as a public
teacher in california and former school
board member she hopes she will help you
see the evidence for yourself
and help you make an informed decision
and we're here to discuss today
with her this film by matt walsh what is
a woman
to get her reaction to this and ours
let's bring out brenda lipsack how you
doing brenda good good to be with you
eddie it's nice to have you back on the
program how's everything with you
everything's
how you been
fighting the fight
yes yes so you got a chance uh to watch
this uh film
yes
woman and also the dr phil show that
matt walsh was on
yeah so what are your thoughts
well i thought what he did matt walsh
and what is a woman is he exposed how
many of our medical experts such as he
interviewed um pediatrics and also um
from tennessee a professor of gender
studies and it just shows how
whack-a-doodle um these people are who
are considered the experts of the field
are saying you know all these genders
and kids can say whatever gender they
want to be and it's just
it's mind-blowing
i want to go ahead and share
a clip
from the film so
some people who haven't seen it they can
kind of get an idea
on what
was being talked about in the film
if i were to say that i'm a black man
could you
would you accept that or would you
be skeptical
are you black are you african-american
are you biracial
i don't think so okay well you don't
look that and i don't think that's a
that it doesn't sound like that's a
genuine statement of who you are
okay so that's my point i i could make a
statement about who i am that's
incorrect
of course i think it's well established
that human beings can lie yes
or not even lie i mean i could just be
mistaken
yeah
[Music]
uh guess this all comes back just all
comes down to really one question
um especially
women
gender and sexuality studies
so so what
what is a woman
what was this this was a professor in
the university
yes gender studies professor in
tennessee university
so what was this uh can you kind of
break down what kind of conversation
were they having and what was the point
that he was trying to make
uh the point is is that you are gender
identity is basically what's between the
ears like how you perceive yourself to
be which could be anything and sexuality
is as you said between the legs um your
genitalia your biological gender
or sexuality yes
so i i noticed that in the film
the there's
a distinction that
they're trying they're trying to make
okay so you have what is it
uh because you you this is what you deal
with on a regular basis so you have
biology and then they try to
separate the two what is it biology your
sex and then your gender
right they're separating the two saying
telling kids that your gender is based
on what you think you are how you see
yourself how you discover who you are
your authentic self and then they
starting in preschool um they have these
books out that tell kids that gender can
change like the weather that you can
um it's based on your feelings and you
can choose your own pronouns and they
can fluctuate so they're literally um
confusing kids and creating a mental
health crisis
through all of these different
choices that confuse adults to be honest
yeah it is something that
obviously um
you had someone like
mario lopez
someone who was speaking one
in one way and i'll share that clip
and then you can see why people
flip-flop and then even people who are
conf not
they uh
pretty much
are speaking out against having uh
children young children exposed to such
things at an early age or at all and
this example is a great one because it's
a celebrity who was speaking out like
many
and then he suffered the backlash you
can't talk about trans kids you know
well that's not racism but yeah it's
it's that's just
what that is is authoritarianism they're
just trying to enforce a certain way of
thinking and behaving and they they go
hard on anybody who deviates poor old
mario lopez
nicest guy that's ever lived he's like
wow i don't think kids should be trans i
mean they're little babies and they're
like what you insensitive is because
they can go after him for something like
that and he'll acquiesce he'll give in
you know and i would say if you come
from a place of love you know you really
can't go wrong but at the same time my
god if you're three years old and you're
saying you're
feeling a certain way or you're you
think you're a boy or girl whatever the
case may be
i i i just think it's dangerous as a
parent to make that determination then
okay well then you're gonna be
a boy or a girl whatever the case may be
and it's it's sort of alarming and my
gosh i just think about the
repercussions later on right mario lopez
one on candace owens show which sounds
like a mad lib of ridiculousness however
it did happen and he is now trending
because of what he said about raising
children and gender identities so what
are your thoughts there because it seems
like some people can come out and speak
out but then he came back and had to
issue he issued an apology right
he had to issue an apology kind of to
protect himself what do you think so it
kind of sets a precedence for anyone
else who will step up and speak out
that they're going to end up
getting in some deep trouble with this
uh movement
well i'm speaking out i'm speaking out
in my school district and the reason is
because people are not identifying terms
even the word transgender is extremism
because in the 2020 sex ed standards put
out by the southern poverty law center
um it literally says in their glossary
that transgender is an umbrella term
encompassing large numbers of identities
so when we have unlimited gender choices
and that's the real definition here and
that's what's being promoted to our
children as young as age three
then
parents need to stand up and say enough
is enough
you uh have seen
why do you think they would use muslim
girls in hijab
um
to
promote this movement
it it's kind of like if you took let's
say um a christian who believes in a
certain value or let's say a jew who you
know he stays away from pork and and
he's dressed in a traditional jewish um
dress and then to promote him eating
let's say uh pork for example there'd be
a big backlash right
why would they do that to go ahead and
put two muslim women in hijab you know
imitating mary the most purest woman or
the mother of jesus and to have
them associated with
with this movement
because they're trying to teach kids a
term called intersectionality which
means that they can have many different
types of identities and hold on to their
religion because they want us to have a
religion that's just outward such as the
outward customs that we practice
without the moral standards so they want
our religion to become an outward shell
that really loses its meaning and
doesn't have any influence about how we
conduct our lives it's just superficial
and that's how they want kids to see
their religious
affiliations
in the film you can see
different academics that's a surprising
thing these are people with degrees
there are people you gave a beautiful
example
of can you share that with our audience
again about a detective and if he's
trying to solve a case
what he's looking for
right i i always tell parents when
they're discussing this issue with their
kids to say if this was truly based on
science then science is objective and
should align along all sciences so i
asked my forensic detective friend who
practiced forensic science for many
years in order to
investigate suspects of crimes when they
were taking blood samples and dna
samples did they ever run across in all
of their decades of practice a
non-binary um person or transgender and
they said no they have never run across
that type of suspect
this is not part of the dna no matter
how you change your clothing your makeup
even your hormones or
or surgeries it's not going to change
your dna
yeah
many people are just really having a
hard time wrapping their mind around
this that's something so obvious
you know it's kind of to the core of the
human being it's uh all the way into the
dna the chromosomes i mean everything
part of
a human being distinguishes if a man is
a man or a woman is a woman it's just
straightforward i mean in the quran we
have it just over and over the man is
not like the woman and then the verses
that talk about it in christianity
judaism is just a straight straight
force it's the beginning of time
how we got to a point where we're even
having there's even a debate on this uh
you watched the dr phil show correct
yes i did is this statistic true is he
quoting facts that half of the country's
divided over these pronouns
half of americans say they feel very or
somewhat comfortable
using gender-neutral pronouns while 48
say they feel very
or somewhat uncomfortable using them
you know i that's the first time i heard
that so i really don't know i'd have to
check that into that but wow
because because you would think now hold
on like
most people they just kind of follow
that's that kind of uh
you know follow mentality um you know
like just blindly
fitting in you know pressure and then
you have in like in the film like people
who are academics and students who are
looking up to these people as educated
and then they start trying to say bring
science into it but there's no science
behind this is there
well um they're saying that there is
which you know what's going on is um in
universal preschool biden's the master
plan that biden wants to bring in for
universal preschool and you can see this
on my website
it has for the national educators of
young children
it says they want to teach gender
identity as
meaning that it's expansive and fluid
viewed by science
however they're changing the definition
of science to mean that a fact is based
on experts opinions and of course they
choose who those experts are
so then you have
people
who are
academics who are in these positions
and now you have a play on words a lot
of it's a play on words play on psych
you can see where
a lot of people who are coming out
uh who have you in the film you have the
person who was who went through this who
went through this change and now is
speaking out against this
and what is a woman yes yes that was
powerful and there's many coming out d
transitioners that are young what is it
what what is it called d transitioners
oh d transitioners and if you ever want
to interview some of them i could get
their names
for you because they have some very
moving powerful testimonies of how
they are now um sterilized they cannot
have children
and they didn't know what they were
getting themselves into they were rushed
into these decisions and their bodies
are mutilated they're having health
issues that are horrific
and it's it's very sad they feel like
they were social experiments and they
were i lived eight years as laura jensen
until i woke up
and realized that it was totally insane
to live this out the the first time
that it happened in the 50s was
christine jorgensen but jenner took it
to the next level wow and the person in
the film by matt walsh what is a woman
talks about
how
they
are the people who are really benefiting
from this is the
drug companies the doctor i went to his
name is dr paul walker dr paul walker
was a homosexual transgender activist he
felt his job was to do like they're
doing today is to introduce people to
hormones and surgery as a process of
treatment now keep in mind dr paul
walker was not just your average
therapist dr paul walker was the author
the primary chairperson and author of
the harry benjamin international
standards of care
the very same standards of care that's
being used today that's called wpath
standards of care his agenda was pushing
transgenderism pushing surgery and
pushing hormones
recklessly
and
really damaging someone's life like mine
he's quoting the the amount of money
it's like 1.3 million
per
if you can get somebody to go down this
route that's how much the
the gain is worth to the
pharmaceutical industry well they're
creating lifetime medical patients out
of healthy children
which is easier to control um
i actually talked to one it's easier to
control people when they're dependent on
the government
um and i talked to a psychiatrist
actually about this and he said
something stunning to me about puberty
blockers that i never thought about
besides all the health risks he said you
know hormones are part of when you go
through puberty you're moving from
childhood into adulthood which also
impacts your thinking and your cognitive
ability to be able to you know you're
losing that imaginary
you know type of life and you're going
into more reality and he said hormones
is part of us developing cognitively
and i thought that was very intriguing
i'd never heard that before um he said
so really when you put kids on puberty
blockers he said aren't you creating a
peter pan syndrome where you're
perpetuating childhood thus people who
are more childlike are easier to control
by
daddy government
yeah they make this uh pitch that it's
something like you know we'll just put
everything on pause as if it's that
simple
and we'll just continue to process while
you figure things out but in his uh
documentary or it's a woman you had
experts coming on also talking about
this is a drug called lepron
that that actually is like pretty much
chemical castration that they give to
people
uh
sex predators and others
it's very scary it can cause cancer it
has a whole list of
very dangerous side effects and to me
this is child abuse to be giving this to
children at such a long age there's no
scientific data to support that it's
safe
as far as we know and it's something
that just unnatural how can they get
away with this it just doesn't make any
sense it really doesn't it is child
abuse because um puberty blockers are
not fda approved for the purpose they're
using it for such as sex changes it is
not fda approved and i talked to a head
endocrinologist of a gender clinic in my
county and he verified that
dr mark daniels
wow that's interesting um you have
wow we can go down just another route
where what we won't at this time but uh
you have
also
they were
talking about
that
people not dare doctors scientists
experts in this arena that they not dare
speak against what the advocates out
there the activists are speaking
in favor of this position but as soon as
doctors they're so fearful of the
consequences
that they keep their mouth shut
yes
a lot of them do
i know that as a teacher i went through
a sexual harassment um training and
they're trying to
totally scare teachers by saying that if
you don't use pronouns that could be
that a child chooses that that could be
considered sexual harassment which would
cause you to lose your job
and
it's yeah it keeps people quiet but
i'm not keeping quiet about it
they had a teacher the other day
say that um she's just will not many
muslim teachers they will not they're
going to have to quit their jobs because
they they can't go along with this
and they're having them in the schools
like usually at the beginning they'll
say okay how many boys are you gonna
give me how many girls because there's a
distinction the boy's a little bit more
rowdy and whatnot so they have to kind
of figure this out but she's like we
can't even say that that was just one
example because they can get in in
trouble
yes i just went through an in-service at
my school where they told us not to
refer to kids as boys and girls instead
to use words like students or scholars
um not to refer to parents as moms or
dads but instead to use the word parents
or partners
when you go they also what's interesting
when you go into the history of
the people who kind of are the
masterminds behind this uh individual by
the name of kinsey do you know much
about his bio and and yes i do
can you can you uh bring us up to speed
there was another individual also it was
got john william money yes yes yes well
i want to this book right here it's
called um as nature made him this is
about john william money and the kind of
experiments he did on children which was
it was horrific i have some quotes here
from john william money um in the time
magazine of april 19th
tell us for the audience have never
heard this name like why are we why are
we bringing up was john william money
who is he okay john william money is the
man the quote-unquote sexologist who
came up with the
idea of gender identity that gender is
based on perception rather than on
biology
so he's the mastermind that he kicked
this off pretty much yes wow so go ahead
what are you going to share with us yeah
i want to share a quote from him in time
magazine it says a childhood sexual
experience such as being the partner of
a relation of a relative or an older
person need not necessarily affect the
child adversely he was an advocate of
pedophilia
um
he also was quoted in the dutch journal
of pedophilia by saying
if i were to see the case of a boy aged
10 or 12 who intensely was intensely
attracted toward a man in his 20s or 30s
and the relationship is totally mutual
and bonding
and genuinely totally mutual then i
would not call it pathological in any
way
wow so
this is totally for um boys
having sex with older men
and he set the stage for all this huh
this is what uh modern-day uh
psychologists psychiatrists and others
who are in this sexologist whatever they
pretty much they go off his work to uh
his formula for what we have today
yes and he studied under alfred kinsey
who said um
sexual kids are sexual from birth
and alfred kinsey um had horrific
he authorized horrific types of research
um to show that babies as young as five
months old have orgasms and he did this
through
pedophilia with a time watch
it's
this is some really mind-boggling
mind-boggling scary stuff let's get into
another clip here
you stood up here and said trans women
are women yes tell me what you mean what
is a womanhood is something that just as
ethan explained i cannot define because
i am not myself
so what did you mean when you said trans
women are women if you don't know what
it means right so here's the thing so i
do not define what a woman is because i
do not identify as a woman womanhood is
something that is an umbrella term it
includes people that describes what
people who identify as a woman i
identify as what as a woman what's your
reaction to that this is the clip from
the dr phil show
it's this circular argument um they
can't identify what a woman is and so
it just shows that we've really lost our
way
and this is really comes down to
breaking apart the nuclear family
when you no longer have any genders male
or female then you no longer have a
family so who is the family
the government hmm
let's get into uh when
matt walsh she took it back
outside
of
the u.s
and he went to a an african village
and this is very interesting to ask them
these questions
and what they what if a man decides that
his his gender identity
is his woman
a woman has its own duty
and a man has its own duty and a lady
cannot duty the duty of a man and a man
cannot do a duty of a woman
can a man
become
[Music]
if you want to become a lady but your
man
you have something wrong
something wrong in your family something
wrong in you
what about if someone was non-binary
non-binary
do you know
like non
like someone is you're not a woman
you're not a man
yeah someone's like someone is neither
there's something else is that
your life
he's saying we have never seen things
like this for a man he has a penis for a
woman he has a vagina so we know this is
a lady this is a man what if it's a
woman with a
what if it's a woman with a penis
[Laughter]
your thoughts
i think it's a great point that we have
in the western world become so
open-minded that our brains have fallen
out
so we need to go back to the simplistic
uh the basics
are smarter than us
there was a grandpa that he visited in
the store and he put a sign up
i don't know if you remember that part
in the film
and that sign was i won't repeat the one
word but he said if you're born with a
you're you're not a chick
so it was just common sense he was just
spitting common
sense
and she's like common sense nowadays is
not common practice
but a transgender councilwoman says he's
a bigot who went to the dark side on her
you are not you're not a woman you don't
look like a woman you don't act like a
woman the confrontation started inside
trans women are
[Music]
aberdeen councilwoman thiessa mesquez
confronted owner don suker about a sign
he posted in his store saying if you are
born with a slang for a male body part
you are not a chick i'm telling you
right now every trans woman trans women
are women well i'm telling you as a man
that's [ __ ]
[Music]
it is it's totally okay you know what
nobody confronts you that's the problem
really if they'd say really what the you
want to bet what the
is you don't have to know how many
people you've embarrassed at city hall
like this happens
my sales go up because people
are wanting this really really really
we're going to show them the side of you
and you do it you do it you do it really
good yes
you are
not waking up you are not you're not a
woman you don't look like a woman you
don't act like a woman really
you're
in the head what's wrong with you
i am i am confronting you yes that you
are
i do think that people should be aware
that center of disease control is behind
this um their definition of non-binary
means gender creative
and that means that kids can make up
their own genders and they call these
genders minorities so under critical
race theory that means that um they
would be considered
the oppressed the marginalized the
minorities where if your biological
gender and you're a cisgender they call
it then you are considered privileged
and an oppressor so they are
incentivizing kids
to become these non-conforming genders
through critical race theory
[Music]
wow so people out there who have
transitioned down this path
you've met a lot
who have come out come back to warn
against this
uh who fell into this trap
so
there there isn't there is uh with the
proper education
um
people can hopefully make the right
decisions now that's what we're trying
to do here because as in the film
the one interviewee who went down this
path he said that he quoted the
statistic that seven or some years after
the fact that this group is the most
suicidal
yes i've been reading some articles
about that
there's a lot of research coming out
about that right now
from heritage foundation i just saw that
so if you want to talk about compassion
and love that's out of the love i'm sure
this is why you're doing it while we're
doing it we're trying to educate
humanity because obviously there's an
attack on our children
it's an attack on us on parents rights
and um your work is just so important so
vital
so how can people
go ahead and connect with you and
get more information on the topic
they can definitely connect on my
website it's www.brenda4kids.com
the number four
brenda4kids.com and there's a contact
where they can email me through the
contact on the website also my website
is in many languages there's a google
translate feature so it can be read in
arabic
or in any language the articles and some
of my videos are now getting translated
into arabic
nice just one last question have you
seen some of these the footage that
they've caught you know a person they
cannot take a child into a strip club
and if they
were caught you know you can get
charged you get arrested but you have
many of these places they invite some of
these people and they're pretty much
just really dressed and decently doing
very provocative dances and kid having
kids put money like you would into a
stripper you know um it's very sad very
sad to see it's not a joking laughing
matter and you see this how are they
able to get away with this and nobody's
doing anything
that's a good question i know in texas
they're trying to
ban that because um they're trying to
come out with laws about that
and
because that was going on in dallas
during pride month this month and there
were a lot of people horrified that
minors are participating and being
brought into this even walking on the
the strip
with the drag queens
and so they're calling this out how it's
being get i don't know how they're
getting away with it
i mean and then you have sex offenders
who are just having like a field day
this is who are they been caught
in these places and uh
they going into
uh women's
rest areas and next you know this is
like a sex offender so it's like it's
how convenient for him to say yeah i'm
i
relate i'm this type of gender articles
where sexual predators have used the
gender identity based on feelings
defense in going into women's bathrooms
and in this particular case they were
arrested throw a little mascara on their
face and they can sit in a bathroom and
wait for a victim
well that's already been happening it's
happened in one of the middle schools
where a transgender
young man um assaulted a girl in the
bathroom
um and and it was the father who was
demonized for trying to protect his
daughter
ridiculous but i will tell you that
after that texas dallas drag queen
situation happened and one of the dallas
um
legislators wanted to ban that with a
law
scott senator scott weiner who is a
senator in california tweeted out that
he wants to pass a law in california
that is going to require a drag queen
101 class
before graduation
wow
yeah
that is um something else uh what
happens is what are they doing if you
conveniently now you are someone who's a
criminal and you're about to go to jail
you're a man and you're like hey
i think i have more fun over here on the
other side with the women
yeah
what happens in this case
oh i'm sure it's happening i mean
they're doing it in the prisons
um yeah so a man so you can a man can
say look i'm a woman and in california
let's say california this is the the we
said uh mecca of this so he can they'll
put him in the jail with the women yes
are you serious
yes
this
and there have been assaults
uh-huh so our women prisoners are not
safe
wow this is uh something really scary
scary um thank you very much uh brenda
we're out of time thank you for sharing
this with us and you guys can go to
purpose
brenda for kids brenda for kids.com to
learn more and um
god bless you look forward to speaking
with you again in the future panda thank
you eddie thank you bye-bye bye-bye
anyway thank you guys for tuning in here
to the show subscribe if you haven't
already hit that notification bell
and you see what's going on you see the
times that we're living in and there's
actually a prediction of this in the
quran
that the shia deen they will look
shaytan will look to change the creation
of god almighty allah so this is where
god conscious people and people who've
even fallen into this there's always
hope god almighty allah is the most
loving the most merciful you can always
change towards
the way of the natural way of the fitrah
come back to your creator
he's the most loving the most kind the
most merciful
because there are so many layers of
deception and so much attack on the
fitra on the natural way so sometimes
people they fall into traps but there's
always room until death to go ahead and
turn back
to make toba
what's called
and for us out there people of
consciousness people of goodness and
morality to stand together to work
together
because you can see
as what was quoted from the dr phil show
if this is accurate half the country is
already divided on this
and you see when people like celebrities
speak out like for example mario lopez
when they speak from their fitrah from
the the innate nature of the human being
to go ahead and reject this they get
attacked they get attacked and then they
go ahead and go back into their shell
and they succumb but
that's why we need to lead the way to go
ahead and be those who invite to good
to warn against evil and we have to do
it with kindness and compassion and what
we're doing it with love but we have to
speak we have to speak the truth we'd
like to have you on matt walsh
from uh what is a woman
if you accept our invitation we'd like
to have you on the program these are the
points
and areas that we can work together
thank you very much subscribe if you
haven't already we'll see you next time
here on the show until then peace with
you assalamu alaikum
assalamualaikum
many of you know eddie the dean's show
name hasn't changed because the message
will stay the same the dean and that's
exactly what he has been consistently
calling to so this effort is long
overdue masjid jim and daoison sir all
of this is manifestation of the deen
providing for the mind body and soul
with this gem subhanallah as we know
eddie has been involved in martial arts
for over 10 years we know the dean show
has been here for 10 years plus let's
let's donate to this cause and realize
that this definitely is a manifestation
of our ibadah of giving for what allah
has given us and giving it back to
something that he loves as you've seen
with the work that he has done being
consistent
and in having integrity with this
message of telling people about allah
from different walks of life and he
definitely compliments the ummah when we
look at the presence of islam and
muslims in america let's donate to this
beautiful beautiful idea that we see he
has the caliber and the integrity and
the wherewithal to see it through may
allah bless you all for your donation
for your contribution for spreading the
link of this message to people to where
they can give to allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala by giving to ones that call to
allah barakallahu fikum don't forget to
support this beautiful beautiful effort
assalamu alaikum
thank
you i cannot leave without giving you a
gift if you're not yet muslim and you're
tuning in to see what these muslims are
talking about and you'd like a free copy
of the quran go and visit the
deenshow.com we'll take care of the
postage and everything and get it
delivered to you and if you still have
some questions
about islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you assalamu
alaikum and if you like this episode of
the dean show
like this video
share this video
far and wide and support us on our
patreon page so we can continue this
work
thank you for tuning in peace be with
you assalamu alaikum